[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
greetings
hello how are you ryan i'm okay
good
good we were adjusting the overhead
light and i stared directly into it so
i'm still seeing spots are you blinded
by the light i was revved up like a
deuce wrapped up like a douche another
round is it douche revved up like a
deuce deuce but uh it sounds like douche
doesn't it it does
it does hey guys thanks for joining me
thanks for choosing this podcast to
listen to today there's a lot of
podcasts out there and you choose chose
us today if you're here for jared
padalecki all i say is if you like the
podcast
subscribe write a review keep listening
i know you just are here for jared but
uh it'd be awesome if you stuck around
wouldn't that be awesome ryan it would
be great yeah because we do some good
work here i think yeah i think we have
some solid interviews and you learn a
lot and we talk about mental health and
stuff and
anyway so thank you thank you for
joining us if you want to follow us uh
uh here's our handles
ryan uh inside to be pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook that's absolutely correct uh
also a few little things i'll let you
know i will be in illinois the weekend
of june 10th with tom welling at
metropolis superman celebration
doing the smallville nights on a friday
we do an improv show we read scenes with
fans so if you're in illinois in the
weekend
also i'll be in australia supernova
um i'll be in australia i think i think
the supernova is something like the 17th
through the 27th we're in sydney then
we're in perth
look online go to supernova
come visit us
uh also may 28th coming up next weekend
uh my bands uh sunspin go to sunspin.com
to get tickets we play two shows 2 pm 6
pm we have a special guest we're gonna
play songs from the album
and i really appreciate it just go to
sunspin.com to get tickets or you can go
to stageit.com and type in sunspin we
look forward to seeing you there also
the if you want to get some merch inside
of you online store we've got great
merch small build scripts signed lunch
boxes
tumblers
pictures
anything you can imagine
uh it's father's day coming up so you
know if you want something there and
also you can get tons of stuff at
thesunspin.com
if you want banned stuff
and you could also cameo me or you could
zoom me uh all that stuff
and that's really about it jared
padalecki i love having this guy on the
podcast he's got a great energy he's so
open and forthcoming and um
yeah
what else would you say about this guy
besides uh what you see is what you get
with jared i think he's uh he's a real
down to earth feller
what would you say
uh walker texas not we're not texas
ranger no just walker just walker just
walker just walker that's right that's
all you can say um jared was in a car
accident
uh
recently and he's okay thank god i'm
wishing everybody speedy recovery and
all the best and my thoughts are with
you guys
and uh
you know he's doing all right so a lot
of stuff but uh why don't we just get
right into it afterwards we'll talk
about oh i want to say real quick hello
to all my patrons out there they support
the podcast and extra ways they give
back if you want to give a give anything
to the patron and become a patron go to
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you uh if you join i'll write
you a message uh thanking you right
after and there's tears and there's cool
stuff and i send merch and all that
stuff patreon.com inside of you and
without further ado let's get inside of
jared
padalecki it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience yeah dawg
what's up brother
all right you're in uh you're in tech
well you're always in texas
i am these days yeah i mean uh last time
we chatted at least on uh podcast i was
in vancouver in my little therma blanket
that's true
how far do you how how far away from
home do you film
uh advanced uh r our studios are kind at
like 51st street and 35 which is about
20 minutes but we go all over the place
we go to like dripping springs and
round rock and
bass drop
so within an hour
holy but i'm home
yeah for all the good and bad that that
uh entails
yeah seriously because you weren't used
to that for so many years where you were
so far away from home you had to move
your life so is it is it is it way
easier having your life all there or is
there more distractions man
it is so much harder
it is right you can't focus much harder
dude if i if i
uh if i go do you want to start are we
starting yeah okay
if i
if i get home or when i got home from
supernatural if it was like 6 p.m and i
was tired
i would like have a beer and go to bed
now if i get home at six and i'm
exhausted it's like dad dad dad dad as a
matter of fact my uh my daughter my
youngest uh
uh it's her fifth birthday today so
happy birthday odette oh dad happy
birthday uh yeah she's at soccer camp so
i have a little window to
to not be uh you know loving all over
but um yeah so these days i get home and
i'm like i want to go to bed
and all the kids are like dad come play
basketball dad come for a walk dad go to
the mailboxes with us that i'm like i
just want to die
so it's good i mean like uh but then
i'll have short days or days off and
then you know get to sleep in a little
bit and kind of take his school and all
stuff so you're an executive producer on
the show
uh yeah yeah on walker and you're also
going to be the executive producer on
the prequel
yeah so with walker
that was
something that
i
um kind of i don't say i thought of it
because
you know no one does it alone but that
was something that i was literally in my
trailer i think season 14 of
supernatural uh so the penultimate
season
for a vocab word um
and
i was like i had read some article about
some
[Music]
law enforcement official on the border
it was it was kind of during all the
stuff where
there was a
migration kind of into the states
and people were getting engaged and i
read an article by somebody anonymous
like an op-ed
and they were talking about like they
they ended up in one scenario they're
doing their job uh they're bound by law
and by duty
but they saw like a three-year-old boy
or something and they had a
three-year-old boy and they were like i
can't do this i can't do this anymore
and so they went and and gave their
badge and their gun
to the captain
uh it was like i you know i i may be
court-martialed i may be whatever lose
my pension but i can't put a
three-year-old in a cage and take him
away from his dad
um and it really intrigued me
um and so then i was like well what
about like i like i want to hear more of
the story you know right
so then walker was kind of uh that was
kind of the inception um and then we
we um
we went to anna fricke who
uh is married to jeremy carver who ran
supernatural for a couple years uh and i
knew her as a friend
um
and i was like well is anna available i
feel like she could do the best job and
she was available and she was with cbs
and she is doing the best job and so it
kind of all fell into place so you were
thinking of doing uh walker it was
already
in motion before supernatural even ended
yeah i mean
it was
it was kind of a funny
sure so
god's honest truth when i was thinking
about walker because i
i i feel like a liar
uh or i feel like i look like a liar
because i i said this many times during
supernatural and i meant it like i want
to retire man like i don't want to be on
camera again i don't want to do fittings
and have pictures taken to me
um and so i was literally like on the
way out and when i started developing
walker
my pitch
unbeknownst to him
but my pitch was that jensen was gonna
be walker
and i was like well he's in texas like
uh he's a good actor like he likes
riding horses uh so you didn't really
have any idea thoughts that i'm gonna do
this somebody else is gonna do this
yeah yeah well no no no no no no i i
mean i i thought i was gonna do this as
far as like i'll be involved in every
script all the casting right right micro
and micro story lines the tropes this
and that but i didn't want to be on
camera i don't want to be on camera uh
but wait a minute wait a minute hang on
a second i'm a little lost you you're on
the show now and it's season two
yeah and you're the lead but you don't
you'd rather not
act anymore you sort of want to retire
yeah yeah yeah which is which is why it
was kind of a funny conversation with cw
i almost was trying to negotiate myself
out of a deal i was like well um you
know
because mark uh
who you know uh who's an amazing man um
it was like well you know if you want to
come back uh into the fold then
uh
like
shoot me holler and i was like well you
know i mean frankly i live in austin
it'd have to be in austin he's like i
understand that and i was like okay uh
well you know like i would need to to be
involved creatively not just
saying the words that are written on
page but like directing the storyline
he's like absolutely you've done 400
television like i was like [ __ ] um well
you know i would need like i would need
like a day or two off every episode and
he was like of course we want you to be
with your family i was like jesus christ
i can't i can't negotiate myself out of
this deal
oh my god yeah so i couldn't be more
proud of walking man i i'm so proud of
our show
uh it's a show for everybody and um
uh so that's kind of how
this happened and now now i'm in now i'm
all in man i'm all in on walker
uh
we have that prequel coming out which
has been a series of like zooms and
whatnot uh over the last couple of weeks
which has been awesome i just saw our
girl our girl catherine mcnamara is
gonna be involved in that
yes do you know her yeah of course she's
been in the podcast she's going to come
back and talk about it
uh amazing yeah she seems lovely so
who's she's who's she playing she's
playing your playing number one of the
caution
she's number one on the call sheet
playing which character
she is playing the first walker in the
state of texas is probably all i can say
[ __ ] i hope not getting in trouble
uh no i don't think so that's that's
pretty badass yeah yeah
she seems awesome man i don't i don't
know her well i know we've kind of
crossed paths
uh well then you helped make that
decision
i'm ep dude well that's what i'm saying
so didn't you didn't really know her but
you knew of her work i mean you didn't
meet with her what happened it's a weird
it's a weird world right now where
we did our we did our background checks
you know what i mean like uh we had
dozens of uh young actresses come in for
uh the role
and
um as it got whittled down we obviously
made phone calls and
checked and like hey is this person like
decent are they good
and
uh catherine has
like the best reputation i've ever heard
anybody have it's unbelievable
background checks on everybody yeah yeah
she's unbelievable
but she seems like a million bucks man i
can't wait to get to know her more and
um i think she's awesome she is she's
beautiful inside out she you look at her
like oh my god she's stunning but then
you're like you meet her and you're like
yeah yeah yeah so that's amazing so
how did it start i mean i you told me
how it started but
uh you know you're thinking of retiring
you've done 400 episodes of television
with supernatural
you're you're not wanting this no more
girls
gilmore
don't forget the gilmore jesus man like
give me some credit man
i give you too much credit bro i give
you too much
no but like what made you go walker's
the thing for me right after
supernatural because you probably got a
lot of offers and people wanted you for
like a lead on other shows no
nope
well i mean like
i'm sure i had auditions available um
uh what i love
uh
loved it and love about supernatural it
was
we always felt like we were like the the
the little engine that could kind of
thing like we were never
getting 10 million viewers you know but
we'd get a million and then it would go
to 3 million or something you know like
people were finding it and going like
damn this show is pretty good
uh and we were like we know like we're
working on
um
and so it was more that was more like
word-of-mouth kind of uh uh fandom than
sort of like well hey there's a
billboard on every street corner and
every neighborhood about
you know real housewives of this or that
or whatever um
and so
uh with walker it honestly became
it for me at least and everybody had a
different uh experience with it but for
me it was sort of like all right well
let's let's give it a shot and it was in
the midst of pandemic
uh
i mean
our first podcast together
was what august or september of 2020
like two months later
um and a lot of the world wasn't
shooting yet and so my my initial kind
of motivation
as far as filming was like i want
my my fellow texans and austinites
austonians uh
to be able to pay their mortgage like
let's tell a cool story and anna fricke
and james kevin fahey and their whole uh
gang and cadre wrote an awesome story
and we have awesome actors and actresses
and i was like well let's let's let's do
it like we'll see what happens who knows
where the world's going i don't know if
the spanish flu or this is a common cold
but let's just you know keep on
trucking on
for
it was almost like you ever see titanic
yeah
okay take it easy
you know like when you when the band
uh realizes the ship is sinking and they
keep playing
yeah yeah it was a bit of that sense
uh set wide
uh on a walker set where it's like all
right well we might get a phone call
tomorrow saying we're shut down for a
week or two weeks and we did get those
phone calls and we might get a phone
call tomorrow that the person a or b or
c test deposit for coping yeah and go
down for a week and we did give this
phone calls um and so we were sort of
just like all right well let's let's
just try and still provide entertainment
let's still tell stories
let's still try and provide joy
however we can
um and so we kept trucking along and
then ended up doing a season television
that i i couldn't be more proud of like
that's weird for me to say like i'm my
own biggest critic but i'm so proud of
walker you know yeah i'm so proud of it
and also being intimately involved as an
executive producer and seeing all the
work that everybody's doing and going
like okay now we have 42 minutes
of television with 18 minutes
commercials um
and i
like
all the gears are clicking you know
inside of you is brought to you by nitsa
no one close to you should have to
endure the dreaded knock on the door the
knock that comes from a police officer
who must tell your loved one that you
were killed in a car crash it's a
message that gets even worse when they
learn that your death may have been
prevented if you had only been wearing
your seatbelt the simple fact is
regardless of what type of vehicle you
ride in seat belt use is the single most
effective way to stay alive in a crash
that's why the national highway traffic
safety administration is spreading the
word we want to raise the profile of
seat belt safety so we can save lives so
whether you're going on a cross-country
trip or just up the street please
buckle up don't risk it and remember
click it or tick it
brought to you by nitsa inside of you is
brought to you by magic spoon how much
do i have to say about magic spoon magic
spoon saved me in a lot of ways
because i'm a big cereal guy and i'm too
old to be eating all the sugary crappy
cereals that i did when i was a kid
as
as delicious as they are
you know you just can't afford to do
that anymore so what happened magic
spoon came out with a cereal that you
can enjoy and you can eat and is much
healthier for you
as opposed to eating all the crap that's
in most cereals
uh zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein only four net grams of carbs in
each
serving only 140 calories a serving keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb tell me about the uh amazing
build your own box ryan that's right you
can build your own box and the available
flavors to build your very own custom
bundle are tell me coco yummy fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies and cream
yes maple waffle blueberry cinnamon plus
the newly reformulated honey nut flavor
that will now be added to magic spoon's
permanent collection i mean it doesn't
really get any better than that if you
haven't tried magic spoon and i've had
friends text me going hey is this a
really good product i mean
i know you talk about it on your show
i'm like yeah i try not to talk about
things that i don't
that i don't like you don't want to talk
about things that you don't really like
or enjoy it's easy to talk about things
that you like that you've tasted that
you've uh you you eat in your house
so magic spoon is definitely one of
those listen it's so easy try it out go
to magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product ryan it's backed with a
hundred percent happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so don't even take my word for it
just do it because you're gonna get your
money back if you don't like it remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode inside of you is
brought to you by helix sleep what do we
do more than anything in life
uh
sleep ryan is that i was gonna say that
were you going to save sleep i was yeah
i was trying to think of a funny answer
but sleep is the correct answer we sleep
we sleep so
what would you say one of the most
important things to have if you're
sleeping most of your life or at least
yeah
a vessel on which you can uh sleep
better and that would be a bed
right you need a good bed
what if i told you that you can get the
bed that's perfectly suited for you
it's like porridge it's the perfect
mixture of what you want at helix
helix sleep you just take a small quiz
even i passed it it's it's it's such a
simple it just
you just write your likes and dislikes
and it kind of
equates the whole thing into
the right sleep for you the right
mattress for you
uh helix sleep has the quiz that i just
talked about it takes two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you i mean why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you
sleep everybody's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers yes you
bet and i took the quiz and i have the
medium mattress like i said it's the
perfect mix for me it's not too hard
it's not too soft it's just
right and i love it it's been awesome
getting message from you guys uh
messages saying how much you like helix
sleep too i really appreciate that and
it's nice to see that people are liking
a product that i'm talking about so if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz order the mattress that you're
matched to and the mattress comes right
to your door shipped for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again thank you lord who wants to go to
a mattress store i don't people are
always lying around on those mattresses
and then you're lying around on them
it's kind of gross helix is awesome but
you don't need to take my word for it it
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 and by gq and
wired magazine so here's how you do it
you just go to helix sleep dot com slash
inside take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside that's helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
i remember the first yeah the first
season it was just a lot like it was
overwhelming for you there was just so
much work yeah and doing that
dealing with your did they did you kind
of like
cater towards your needs and like to
make it so you're fresh you feel like
you're alive on set you feel like you're
enjoying it so you're not overworked did
that kind of get into the conversations
yeah yeah for sure man they they take
great care of me uh our line producer
and our onset producer
uh john patterson robin they
they fight really hard to make sure that
you know my days are condensed like i'm
not first up at last up and then waiting
around my trailer for oh yeah and so
logistically this may be boring um but
logistically they've made it
like they're they're treating me like a
like a king you know what i mean and i'm
grateful and i want to give that back to
them and go like all right
uh i will give you everything i have
because y'all are already giving me
everything you have
uh it's still a lot like i'm still tired
i'm still sort of like
how many pages do you have to memorize a
week
let's say there's 45 50 pages
how many do you learn
how many are you in
you're a walker
uh
a lot you know and you know this very
well like sometimes there's a day of
stunts and it's two pages because
there
is going to be a six-hour stunt scene or
whatever uh and then some days there's
eight pages uh i will say that i'm kind
of a funny
i don't even i don't know funny maybe i
should drink something i'll i'll take
that back i'll retract that uh um i
i i
like i i don't know how you feel about
this but like when people say like oh
you're an actor you must be a great liar
like for me i kind of bristle a little
bit and i'm like i'm not lying like
i'm going through something like i as an
actor my job is not to lie
it's to tell the truth it's not my truth
but my job is to tell the truth unless
my character is lying you know right
right
or something and my job is to be
two-faced
uh and so i i do a lot of work uh
outside of uh set uh before the world
wakes up and after they go to sleep and
all this stuff uh so my my thing is that
like i i want to almost be indoctrinated
to whatever character i'm playing like i
want to read it over and over again and
read it when i'm walking and read it
when i'm
on the treadmill and read it when i'm in
bed and read it when i'm
on the couch with kids watching tv or
something until
i get to the point where like i'm on set
and i'm just telling the truth because i
know that truth now it's almost like
i i've been indoctrinated
yeah
um
and so i do a lot of work i know you do
a lot of work and i know like i just saw
this article come up on twitter today
and it was i guess
it was that whole gilmore girls thing
where you're out with your buddies one
night and you're partying and uh for
some reason uh lauren uh from gilmore
graham got sick they had to switch
scenes around and so
paint that picture exactly what happened
because this kind of got your work ethic
to where it is now in a way right yeah
literally it was it was sort of like one
of these one of these situations where
on kilmer girls i think i was number 12
or 15 or something on the call depending
on uh whether it was season one or five
uh or anything between um and
i think i was filming like just as an
example and i remember the exact details
but i wasn't filming for several more
days um and then
we all stayed up and it was pretty
i was gonna say
like we were we were
you know
having a crazy time it was like me and
my my buddies like playing grand theft
auto that are just coming out and i had
one of those big old i think like one of
the first things i bought on gimbal
girls was one of those giant tvs that
weighs as much as the car
and takes up a giant amount of space for
those people who were born before 2000
they used to be giant and it was like
plasma you know ps3 or ps2 or ps1
whatever it was and we had grand theft
auto and so we'd sit there and play i
had like my puppy and this net
uh and so we had stayed up like
playing games ordering papa john's
uh
and probably like drinking coors light
or some redneck stuff it was like a lot
of texans also um
and so then we went to bed around
whatever time
didn't didn't go nuts we weren't like
drinking booze like taking whiskey shots
right but we're just like drinking beer
and staying up late um and then i had a
puppy at the time
sadie city girl who who passed away and
koda who you met last time uh he had
surgery so he's not here right now
otherwise i'd bring him in for a cameo
i'll i'll get back around no i like it i
like it
so
so
like went to bed and i had gone to home
depot and bought like
plywood and
sod
and
uh turf and i made this like four by two
my daddy and i had made this four by two
like little pee place for sadie to go to
the bathroom on my balcony because i
lived on the third floor
of uh
4301 fulton for
i don't live there anymore uh but 4301
fulton so it was like two blocks up from
uh casa vega right
right on the little exactly where that
is yep yeah and my neighbor uh
yeah anyways and you're close to work by
the way that's relatively 10 minutes
away from work dude i was down riverside
or or more park yeah it was right there
right there 50 minutes in l.a
um and so
i
had left the
screen door open to the balcony going
like okay she kind of knew and there's
like some spray that smells like
urine i guess
uh but you spray it where you want your
dog to pee so like if you live in an
apartment in new york or l.a or san
francisco then they're like well this is
like the thing that you can do to make
your dog pee here because they smell
urine they want to pee i guess this is
kind of disgusting i'm sorry it's uh
it's educational it's okay
so
so i had that stuff and like sprayed it
and i was like okay i'll leave this i'll
leave this uh door open
and then all of a sudden i'm woken up at
like eight in the morning my buddy
jordan uh what's up jordan uh
who's one of my dear friends stood in my
wedding and he's like hey man they need
you on set and i was like this isn't a
funny joke like leave me alone you know
like
turning over the pillow
and he's like no no they like uh spilo
called me who's my my manager produced
partner
uh dance pillow and
he's like no they they've been calling
and i was like what are you talking
about i got my phone which is probably
like a
not even a motorola razer it would have
been whatever the little small phones
were right nokia
nokia pro nokia nokia nokia
no nokia he says and i had a bunch of
missed calls and voicemails and texts
right and i was like oh jesus
and so i get up and then i find out the
story but you know it's time you're 20
and so a cold shower and a cup of coffee
you're like all right were you running a
marathon or what but it was the worst
feeling it was like the the the the
classic like naked school uh trope or
whatever right where it's just and i was
like i never want to be there again
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help us customize online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than an
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
inside of you listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better h e l p dot com
slash inside get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
inside
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available 24
hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
you just felt like you're not prepared
you you know you you kind of lost you're
getting on set you're kind of like
it just was really uncomfortable for you
it was more than uncomfortable man like
it was it was
scarring
frankly like like ptsd not like legit
ptsd but it was like it stays with me to
this day like what was it was it
embarrassing because you didn't know
your lines or
no man like
everybody on set was kind and gracious
and
they knew me and i knew i could do a
good enough job i suppose
um not really being prepared but i just
felt like i was being an [ __ ] like i
felt like i was
as nice as ever as being
i felt like they must hate my guts like
here i am some 19 year old kid
showing up
probably smell like coors light
um and
they have family i don't have family you
know like well i had family but i have
kids or something right right right
but i just felt like
man i
like these people's
time is valuable
uh and here i come showing up and you
can't explain to 100 people like hey
here's the deal i didn't know i thought
i was gonna work in three days from now
i'm sorry they don't care they don't
care right
you
they probably don't care but also you
don't have the time to go around to
every person and say like listen this
sounds like an excuse
uh it's not like it's legit story like i
woke up after four hours of sleep to
find out i was working today
not four days from now and so i just was
mortified and i felt like i let i felt
like i let people down and they were all
super gracious about it like they were
all like hey we're all doing different
things that we thought we were going to
do today and so i was like all right
they were they were very gracious uh and
that was a teaching moment for sure
but uh but yeah i informed who i am now
and now like my my
my
uh
work ethic
yeah
i was kind of laughing because i i
wanted to say
um
like it doesn't speak to my ability to
like it's not like if i don't do a good
job it's not because i haven't done the
work it's because i don't have the time
it's kind of humbling it's like humbling
self-deprecation right there if i ever
mess up a scene it's not because i don't
know the scene it's because i don't have
the talent so you're not the company
yeah so you're not the kind of actor
that can just walk on set learn lines in
the trailer you're not doing that
i don't know man i've never tried it
you've nev so you know
you know all your lines but when you
come on set you know every line of the
script
i know everybody else's lines uh but
here's here's something i went through
in high school i did well in school i
you know my mother's teacher
uh retired my father's an accountant and
uh like they were both academic and uh
and i i sort of like found pride or or
found some joy and going like i didn't
read the book i just read the cliffs
notes and i'm gonna get a good uh grade
on the test
and then about a year into that i was
like i'm just
i'm just like hurting myself
like i
by by trying to
shortcut my way into uh getting an a on
the test i'm only taking away my own
experience reading this
wonderful author's words and
experiencing it uh
as they wrote it and so it was kind of
that experience so it's not that i don't
want to
it's not like to prove a point of like
i'm sure i could go on set tomorrow
we're not filming tomorrow i'm sure i
could go on set at walker
and read my scene for the first time and
do a decent enough job but i'm only
stealing from me like and i like to when
i'm when i'm going to set
i like to have a good time like i like
to go in the scene and go like i know my
words i know the phenomena and if you
don't you're stressing and it's like
it's a different vibe it's a different
feeling but also but also it's it's it's
kind of comically
it's you're only hurting yourself man
because you're not able to really get
into fine little nooks and crannies that
you don't find when you're reading it in
your uh couch or in your bed or
something and so
i i realized that i was just kind of
like cutting off my own nose to spot my
face yeah i was like all right well i'm
going to do all the work so that when it
gets set i'm just ready to play and like
have a good time and enjoy the concert
you know what i do that too i i don't
want to go on set and all of a sudden
they surprise me with something i want
no surprises i want to know that i'm
prepared for every scene that they want
to shoot in that script and that's hard
but you're the lead role so that's a lot
of time that you're taking to learn
these scripts and then you get another
script in next week do you have someone
who's running lines with you does your
wife help you or do you just do it on
your own
i'm a i'm a loner man i mean like if i
wasn't an actor i like i always say i'd
want to be like a wildlife photographer
in
africa i'm not kidding like i'm i'm a
i'm a big like i'm in my house right now
like i i don't go out
i love i i don't like people but i love
good people but that makes any sense and
so i don't want to be around the masses
i was never the guy who knew what the
hot club was in la and all that and not
that there's anything wrong with those
people by any means i just that's not
the way i'm wired right
uh i'm wired to kind of
like be alone and beat myself up a
little bit and that's probably not great
but i'm just wired to go like okay i
want to do the best i can
like i'm not what's funny is that like
i'm i'm a competitive person but not
with you not with anybody else i'm
competitive with myself so i compare
myself to other versions of myself
if you if if i do my best and you do
your best and you win
chess or basketball or whatever then i'm
like cool i did my best but if if i feel
like i haven't done my best then i i'd
dwell on it man it's not good but now
i'm dealing with it can you watch
yourself do you watch yourself and can
you appreciate it or are you one that's
just like uh too critical
i didn't watch
supernatural uh
when it was on like i wouldn't watch the
live airing unless it was like jensen
hour on set and we'd go to his trailer
and watch it live tweet or something
uh with walker i do because of my
capacity as ep
right so i have to give notes i'm like
hey let's let's draw this fight scene
out or
hey i think we have a cut and so
but it's it's when i watch it it's very
mathematical it's very sort of like
it's critical
uh not necessarily uh
negatively critical but it's more like
okay we need this cut to be this can we
think about act four ending the scene
prior because
it cuts the flow so it becomes very it's
it's very mathematical which kind of the
way i think
like i don't think i'm an artist i think
i'm a craftsman you know
um because i think of things in a
certain structure right um
and so i i do watch walker and i and i
watch it with my kids you know like if
if they're
uh
home and awake than a friend's house
then we'll we'll still watch it on
thursdays which is great because on
supernatural
you know which i
love the mark um
but i'm like cutting somebody's head off
or getting my head cut off or something
that's right right it wasn't something
you want to show the kids at like 8 30
p.m
and then they're like okay go to bed
it would have felt a little longer yeah
i mean because jensen always came on set
and pretty much learned the lines there
right in the trailer
yeah yeah
his we have kind of opposite work ethics
no no no no he works hard as [ __ ] well
yeah i'm not saying he didn't work hard
but like to say that you just dissect
everything and just really do all the
work at home i would say i would say i
would say he and i have kind of polar
opposite
methods because i mean his work ethic is
legendary like he he works as hard as
somebody can work on something he just
does it in a different way you know
right right um
so he
he would say and you don't you know like
i have to take his word for it like we
live together for a while but yeah he
likes to get there and it'd be fresh and
i've worked with and i'm sure you have
as well i've worked with some people who
who are full method and don't leave
character for the entirety of
the shoot what's the line from uh robert
downey jr and trump defender he's like i
don't leave character until the junket
is done or whatever it is
yeah yeah it's such a good movie uh
anyways um
but
he
and it's a it's a it's a it's a trial
and error process and i guess for him he
found out through his hundreds of
episodes of television
as well that the way
he
feels like he's giving his best is to
keep it fresh and yeah you know
good like that that's
it's like i
you ever hear like don't yuck my yum you
ever hear that i've heard of it yeah
it's like i'm
you do things the way you do and that
works for you i do things the way i do
that works for me i'm not gonna yuck
you're young
right yeah i hope you don't yuck maya
like i like frankly i wish i had more
jensen in me uh because i'm setting my
alarm at 4 30 a.m you know get out of
bed with my beautiful stunning wife to
go get on my treadmill and read and i
wish i could find a better way to go
about it i know a lot of fans would
probably like to yuck your yum
did i go too far
no i think maybe i'll have to cut that i
don't think so i'm gonna oh no i'm gonna
grab something
[Laughter]
this is not a growler of beer this is
kombucha and this is not like a paid
advertisement does it taste good
no
sure it's just really healthy
you know i heard some like
maybe a podcast about kombucha and
microbiome and how kombucha is good for
you and so i bought some and it was
absolutely disgusting
but i powered through it right and now i
kind of like it
yeah really what is it what does it do
for you because you're you're kind of a
health nut right
i'm not i try to be dude i'm gonna be 40
in july dude i'm going to be 50 in july
get out of here
7 11.
no way you're okay we talked about it
yeah yeah i'm 7 19.
uh so i'll be 40. you'll be 40 i'll be
50. 10.
matching tattoos
maybe
maybe
i got to do something for my 50th i
although i feel like doing nothing i'm
just like oh my god saying you're 50 is
just that's the hardest part when you
don't feel 50 it's just like saying i am
50 years old it's
it's impossible to fathom it's like i
want to say i'm 38. i'm 41.
let's just say an inspiration if you
look like this at 50 then i got to get
back i'm gonna go
do you mind if i'm doing push-ups yeah
do some push-ups i didn't shower today
either i look much better the shower
have you not hey you you said something
also that was on twitter i just i just
if i didn't look at this i wouldn't have
found all these little gems but you said
that supernatural almost didn't hire you
or cast you because
you felt like they thought you was too
stupid no no not i felt dude i was with
the actor talk to me
the other day so this is really funny so
i'm sure you kind of remember these days
but for those who are listening in the
early 2000s
if you were auditioning if you were
if you looked like
michael rosenbaum or jared padilla
it was very like they wanted to be like
broody you like brooding like like sort
of like uh like oh i'm thoughtful i'm
pensive
um and so kripke and dude uh kripke was
in town
for south by southwest for the boys and
so he and i and eccles were uh hanging
out gosh couple days ago
um but i was teasing him about it and so
i went in
and i was on gilmore girls and i was
doing the whole brooding like
uh i'm james dean cause that's what
worked back in the day when you were
auditioning and uh the the the
critique or response came back to my
manager spiele that i talked about
earlier
uh and it was like well
uh crippy's looking for an intellect
like a david de company type
and so
which which wasn't directly saying like
well we think jared's stupid uh but so
my manager had to call and go like hey
listen he missed one question and matt
from sats he's a national merit scholar
he's a debate champion like he's just
okay give him that note let him come
back wait a minute wait a minute you
were your sats were that high
they were all right yeah i mean i missed
one question math
so you got like what a 13 1400 on your
sats
yeah 1490 i think
are you freaking kidding me but i only
took when i was a sophomore but you're a
genius
i'm not a genius man i don't think i
don't think i mean that's incredibly
bright
i don't think i got half that
i'm not kidding talk about i don't want
to sit here i know that my fans get
upset when i call myself
not you know call myself stupid or
whatever but i'm not saying i'm stupid
i'm just like
i was never great with tests man i see
that's that's the thing is that i i did
well in tests
the smartest most interesting intriguing
people i know
by and large didn't do well in tests
because their brain just goes from a
different angle and so like i i feel
like this is me beating myself up or
something uh but i i
i would rather be around an interesting
person who has questions about the world
than somebody who got a 1600 okay good
good then we can hang out then
that's good but but
but tell me
tell me about this tell me what we're
gonna do for our 50th and 40th and you
avoided it no i would dude i would love
to i would love to celebrate with you
i'd love to go up those spiral staircase
right there i'd like to spend the night
there at the padalecki homestead
come over i would love it if i'm ever in
austin or anything i'm i'm crashing
there i'm visiting you
no doubt about it so wait a minute so
your agent says to you dan is that his
name dan
yeah manager manager and he says hey so
he wants to tell you to go in and do it
again
yeah and i i watched i watched the and i
had like a
did you ever like a holding deal with
warner brothers back when it was one of
those tv uh maybe i don't remember it
wasn't for much money but yeah we're uh
back in the early 2000s i don't know if
this is the same situation now and i'm
trying to in my head make sure i'm not
breaking any rules but they would they
would like somebody like uh jared or
michael and they go like hey we want him
to be on this show
but we want the right to have him
uh
at our disposal for
our next series of pilots for whatever
they might do right so they give you a
check
and you have like a pre-negotiated
uh
episodic
pay for the next year
and so that's where i was and where
apples was because he was on smallville
awesome gilmore girls
and uh and so they kind of go like all
right well we want
after this year gilmore girls we want
jared to beat about this show called
supernatural
um and
so i went and admit and i was wearing a
beanie big surprise and like a hoodie
and probably like flip-flops or
something
and back in 2005
the game was like if you can go in and
pretend you're james dean that you're
gonna get the role you know it's sort of
like all right well i'm gonna go in i'm
gonna squint the do you know the labored
inhale jensen and i are
mastering this would you like to see it
sure
okay
your whole face changed
the whole face changed there it is there
it is
if you watch any tv show that existed in
the early 2000s you'll see a lot of
labor enhancements
so
that was kind of the move you know
because it was like well i'm auditioning
i haven't even given the script
uh i'm reading some lines like i should
be doing something i'm going to do this
and act brooding and all that um
and so and that didn't work man
that didn't work
it didn't work no no i think i think uh
david nutter liked me who directed the
pilot and the first episode wendigo he's
producer uh mcgee
peter johnson
uh but i think kripke was like well
he just seems like he's using tricks and
i was using tricks so he was right
uh he was correct uh but then so spielo
calls he's like hey they
i don't think they like got really a
good sense of you
um so why don't you go back in and uh
be more smart
[Laughter]
so i was like all right so i went in
like talked literature and stuff i was
like all right like shakespeare
uh theater super girl uh like what do
you want to talk about and they're like
okay this guy doesn't know how so you
literally had a conversation and just to
show them that you're not some schmuck
well i went in and dude like i i
i have anxiety anyways i know yeah um
and so going into auditions when it's
gonna possibly change your life
you just get so nervous
that you can barely string together a
sentence and that's been funny about the
walker prequel is watching people's
auditions and trying to figure out like
who
is
seeming slightly off because they're
possibly nervous and who just doesn't
have by like
finding out who's capable who can handle
this
yeah and it's it's a crapshoot right
you're like it's like betting on a
crypto currency or something right right
right it just seems like the one that's
gonna stand
yeah um this one i don't think and so
it's it's so difficult from a two-minute
audition tape to kind of
uh try and
judge or grasp the the the wherewithal
of a human being to be able to to do a
tv show for how many years right
man
so they thought you were
not that bright you had to go in there
you had to sell yourself and i don't
think they i think and i'll say this to
just because i i said it to him the
other day i think it was kripke it was
like
we want somebody smart like the company
yet they didn't know that you had an sat
score of like 1490. holy [ __ ] that's
brilliant
i don't know it's really man it's just
testing i think that's pretty brilliant
that you could do it you know we always
talk about mental health and like you
know anxiety and depression all these
things
how are you dealing with all that stuff
right now i mean are you are you
exercising like crazy what are you doing
uh i'm
i'm kind of in maintenance right now i
went out to see a doctor in costa mesa
uh
in november named dr daniel amen
and he did some brain scans and
it was pretty humbling man like i so my
wife and i jennifer and i went out
and did brain scans and my brain
has like 60 percent of the oxygen
going to it that it should
yeah i just took a deep breath
i broke down in tears i was like what
uh but then he kind of said something
pretty magical he's psychiatrist
uh he said something pretty magical
uh he's like well dude if you're if
you're he doesn't say dude he's too
smart i'll say dude you could say dude
maybe he said dude i don't know right
but he basically said like if you're
doing everything you're doing right now
at 60
of oxygen to your brain
then once we get you all squared away
uh you know sky's the limit and so i've
been doing hyperbaric uh does that
really work be honest with me
i don't know i don't know i don't know
but you're doing it hyperbaric chamber
you do that how often have you done that
i've done it every day this week
you have one at your house
yes
you have a hyperbaric chamber at your
house how much does one cost
it's not cheap 10 000
a little bit more
and you and the wife use it constantly
i use it she has something in her
genomics that
makes it less than ideal
uh we have a doctor here in town as well
uh a physician and
like she's a like you know 23 and me yep
yep well this is like 350 of me like and
so she goes through like apoe 3 and this
and that and what you're
more than likely going to do and so for
jen for whatever reason by the way jen's
brain was
beautiful like brilliant like blood
going everywhere i'm like i'm not
surprised she's perfect
uh mine looked like swiss cheese man
like uh it scared you
i've
broken down into tears like really
did the doctor immediately say hey hey
hey this is not you're not dying or
anything this is just something that we
can correct
yeah he's psychiatrist and so he was
like okay here's where we are now and
here's
what we can possibly do to make it
better and so for me you know i'm a
fortunate dude uh been working hard and
saved money in this net
and i i was able to afford uh to have
one of those machines in my house
um
but for me it came down to like well if
i
can
live with my uh faculties for a couple
years longer beyond my kids
then like i i'd rather have that than
more money in the bank when i die yeah
that's and i i hope that doesn't sound
callous like i i i realize there are a
lot of people all over the world who are
not in the same situation but
you know in the current situation i find
myself in i was able to kind of justify
it do your kids want to get in the
hyperbaric chamber they're like dad let
me go in there my sons have my daughter
hasn't but you you can't do it as high
power there you have to be able to
pressurize your ears and stuff and so my
sons have gone give him a coloring book
what does it do what does it do just
provides more oxygen to the brain yeah
yeah basically uh to everything you know
to your to your epidermis um so it it it
ups the level of oxygen from kind of
like one psa or psi rather uh complex
square inch to like 4.2 mine does
um and so the idea is it it floods it's
almost like having a uh like those like
oxygen bars and stuff where you put a
mask on
you have one that was my dog i just went
out
i i think
the so there's something called like
your telomeres and that's
that's an indicator of your biological
age and i think an institute in israel
did a study
uh where they would take you or me and
test our telomeres and then they put you
on
a protocol of like 60 hyperbaric
sessions
in 90 days and me not and yours would go
down like 10 to 20 years
so biologically you're younger and i
don't know i mean i'm not a physician
but you don't but you don't really feel
any different yet
so far
i don't know i don't know there's too
many variables i'm working my ass off
you know we're developing the prequel
and i'm working hard on walker i have
three kids and
i'm pushing 40 so
you'll tell me in a year next year when
we talk again
you'll let me know how you feel
all right but you're going to
consistently do this
you're going to consistently you're
going to give this all you got you're
going to give it a chance you're gonna
see how it works because people some
people swear by it
yeah and also for me
um again i keep put i keep like bumping
on i'm turning 40 in a couple months but
my genevieve was like hey
like
what do you do do you want me to plan
your 40th birthday or do you want
something like what do you want like i
want to make this special
and she was like what what do you want
for your birthday and my answer was
honestly
a nap
like
you know
she's like jared stop it seriously
seriously jared yeah i know and i was
like no honest god like if i could take
a nap on my birthday then i'm square man
do you not take naps during the day do
you not take naps on walker
i'm napping right now
uh
you're a zombie i do dude i i i can nap
standing up i'm i'm just pretty tired
these days uh but that haven't been said
uh if i'm here and i'm gonna nap for
half an hour an hour i can nap in the
hyperbaric you know right and ideally
hopefully be around
uh for my kids for longer you know yeah
i read somewhere i know this is a weird
thing to bring up but you know we talk
about
mental health you know on the podcast
you talk about this i know you're an
advocate
you're very open you've helped many many
people but i know today
is supposedly the birthday
of your old stand in matt who had passed
away from suicide years ago but today
coincidentally is his birthday
that we're recording this
and
is there something that you want to say
in in response to just like you know
someone who we lost to you know too
young and someone who we didn't know we
weren't aware of the problems that were
going on and is there any insight you
can give to that
yeah man uh
i don't know if it's inside as much as
opinion
or maybe this is anecdotal but you got
to be open man like matt riley uh
rest in peace
uh was the best dude
and i know you met him because he had
done tom yeah
um
and
it was just the smilingest guy who was
going through a lot of stuff and i think
and i've learned this being married um
like my wife can't read my mind i can't
read her mind and so if you got
something going on
just be open
you know yeah um and i i went through
some tough times
um
and i thought like well if i just push
down further it'll go away it it didn't
you know
uh it is now you know like but it got to
a boiling point
but yeah i've got a few friends uh who
are no longer around uh
due to suicide
um
and it's tough because it's never the
person who's
well at least in my
experience limited
um
it never is the person who's walking
around going like man i'm so bummed i'm
so bummed it's always a person who's
like hey man how are you
and then they say you you get a text or
a phone call like hey they're not here
anymore you're like so usually the signs
are tough because there are no signs a
lot of times yeah i think a lot of
people who
are going through
really difficult times
have been
to places in their head where they don't
want somebody else to go to that same
place and so they just hide it right
you know
yeah it's tough i mean that's what i
mean we always have an open you know
it's just one of those things where it's
just like just
somebody says how you feeling with my
friends how are you feeling be honest if
something's going on let's talk about it
you know it's trying to keep an open
dialogue and some people are private
some people don't want to share and i
think that the stigma you know with
mental health and talking about your
problems and all these things i think
that's starting to go away i think
people are starting to open up more i
think there's more therapy
it's on the right trajectory it's on the
right trajectory i believe
um by the way do you
uh
you still have the winchester car what's
the the uh
it's in my garage yeah do you drive it
ever
it has a has a uh
a leak right now in one of the gaskets
i do i'm gonna get it fixed up um yeah
jensen has one i have one how much do
you think that car is worth if you were
to sell it
what are you offering
could you sell it for could you sell it
for 50 100 grand
i don't know i wouldn't i wouldn't sell
it you wouldn't sell it it's just like
it's a part of you you're not going to
sell this
yeah and it's also uh
so we have like number one number two
number three
and number one had a 502
uh big block in it um
from gm
uh and that went to jensen
but number two ironically we used more
because
it was quieter so we wouldn't get noise
complaints and so that's sitting right
there so you got the quiet what's it
called what's the car called
the baby is it what's called baby oh
it's the same ball we call it baby yeah
is that what you called it on the show
yeah
who came up with that or was it written
uh it was written i don't know who came
up with it probably crooky
my guess right
i don't know did uh i know jared came
and directed an episode of watching yeah
do you like when he directs do you do
you feel kind of comforted do you like
him on set uh on another a total
different production but there with you
does it feel like hey my partner in
crime's with me
yeah and what's funny is
he was gonna direct last year and then
he's doing the boys up in toronto
um and so he directed this year
and
i had i wasn't in every scene and so i
had like two days off of a principal
production photography right and we
scheduled them for the first two days
and on purpose because i wanted my
walker crew and cast to know like hey
jensen's not here because he's my friend
he's here because he's a savvy and
talented director
like this is your director this isn't
like hey jared's buddy is coming along
to direct an episode
no ma'am no sir
um and so he did the first two days of
filming without me on set
and then i showed up on day three which
i believe was his birthday march 1st
um and was able to kind of tell the crew
um
you know
we talked about this earlier but when i
was basically talking to pedowitz
at cw and going like well i i'm not
unwilling to work again it would have to
be in austin it was like
cool tell me more i was like well
i would need to be involved cool tell me
more
that wouldn't have existed without uh
the work that echols and i did on
supernatural and i think um
this is gonna sound really weird and
i've thought about this
but i don't think there's anybody on the
planet that believes in jensen
to the degree i believe in jensen wow um
and i
i have no doubt that his his wife and
kids and family and friends
know that he walks on water
the difference is that i've seen him
walk on water
you know what i mean like day in day out
for 15 and a half years i've seen him
with a cold um
i've seen him get bad news about
his grandma and go back to set i've seen
him
get bad news about oh a pipe burst at
her house and kind of shake it off and
go back to set so
i love the guy dearly uh always will
and
i
you know it's one thing to know like
somebody you like
is a hero it's another one it's another
thing to to see them
and why they're a hero you know so
uh having him on set and
we what's funny on walker
a lot of
a lot of our crew say that like
crew members friends of theirs from
other shows will call them be like hey
how's disneyland you know
we have a great set man right and
uh
you know
we're all a part of it
but as the ep and the lead
i i help set the tone you know i have a
heavy hand i guess and set in the tone
um
and i i i had the chance to tell
everybody with echoes there
like hey
this wouldn't happen if it weren't for
the blood sweat and tears of this guy
for 15 and a half years as well
um
and for them to kind of honor him as
well because they hadn't the chance to
meet him yet you know and covet as well
he would have come by many times it's
amazing you know what's more amazing you
know what's more amazing is that you
work for 15 years
and sometimes you feel like the last
person i want to see
is the person i've been working with
every [ __ ] day
and then for you to get on your own show
an ep and say
i want jensen to direct an episode sure
is that just speaks more volumes than
you know i'm sure he was very touched
and
you know
yeah and he's a phenomenal director man
he's a phenomenal actor director
everything like the the guy can do
whatever he wants uh and and
do it with with
ease and
you know
yeah any uh any new fights or are you
kind of the fist of cuffs you've kind of
laid off that for a bit buddy i yeah i'm
taking a break taking a break from that
a little a little fight sabbatical i i i
i don't want to go back to jail so um
i'm i'm avoiding that uh
oh man
oh boy uh this is why are you giving it
a shot yet no no fights for me uh you
know i try to keep calm you know
you know i'm not as big as you either
i'm not as strong as you where were you
two years ago i could have used this uh
tidbit of advice
yeah right you don't need to fight
that's all you want to do is you want to
hear people preach to you
yeah you made a mistake it happened [ __ ]
happens yeah
this is called [ __ ] talking with jared
padalecki these are rapid fire you can
answer them the way you want if you want
to take a beat betsy d this is from my
patrons these are uh go to patreon.com
inside of you join patreon uh help the
podcast give back we love you and i'll
message you right after here we go betsy
d i love walker how was it with jensen
we already you already talked about this
how was it directing an episode of
walker any other tricks or pranks played
by either of you
uh so betsy d
uh
it was awesome uh being able to show off
my buddy uh my my partner in crime my
brother many years and
many years to come um
we we had a bunch of pranks planned some
had to get kind of shelved
uh due to like coveted restrictions and
stuff like that uh but we we had
different uh director chair back names
for him every single day so the first
day he showed up it was dean winchester
second day of soldier boy from the boys
and then it was like red hood and
uh we had a few it was like daniel's
husband uh did you just put it with tape
tape and a marker on there no no
our chair backs here they their velcro
and so we just we printed a bunch out um
that's amazing how did he feel about
that did he love it he was laughing man
yeah he appreciated it that's good
little lisa what's your favorite thing
about doing conventions
you know my favorite thing these days it
changed it's changed a lot uh over the
years my favorite thing is catching up
with
people
i've
known for a long time and some brand new
people about something that i'm really
passionate about it's like you know you
walk into a restaurant and you find out
someone's a fan of your favorite
football team or
band you see somebody with a pearl jam
shirt and you're like oh i love pearl
jam and they're like oh i went to them
in kansas city in
you know 2006. like i was there too you
know so it's it's it's connection it's
connection
it's a connection it feels like catch-up
with old friends
and i found as i
as i age
um
have more experiences
all over the place that
it's it's those small connections
between
people that really excite me and so i
think
what excites me the most about
conventions is the opportunity of a
uh see
a lot of the fandom uh some new some
long-standing
um
and b
see people that i've worked with you
know and we talk about like the scene we
shot in 2008 in vancouver we're getting
pissed on with rain and lightning and
thunder and you know catch up with
samantha smith or felicia day or kim
rhodes or whatever and you're going like
you remember that scene where we had the
fake blood and it's freezing and you're
like yeah so it feels like a
everyone feels like a ring i love it
emily yes would you go back if they did
another gilmore girl show like netflix
did a few years ago
yes you would do it
i would yeah yeah oh that's fine i look
different i i have to like dye my hair
look at this
you see are you getting a few grays
there that's what i'm getting see i got
those grays too weird you know there was
this app last night i was looking at
jared and it showed you with blonde hair
not you the proverbial you like yourself
wait what time last night were you
looking at i don't know i was looking
looking at my this app and it showed me
with blonde hair and i was like what
were you wearing
i was naked except you know i was in my
bed by myself
but i saw myself with blonde hair and it
kind of not to say it turned me on but i
thought maybe i should get my hair
uh lightened is that kind of is that
kind of sad
no it's good it's good i like it i like
it yeah we all go through our uh own
trials and tribulations
we have a hot tub outside in the
backyard and uh my daughter who turned
out today again again
this couple days ago a dad
so we're there and we're playing around
and she likes to do this thing she goes
like make a bridge and that means like
stick my legs crossed so she can either
swim under it or crawl over it and then
she's like okay uh and she wanna give me
a hug and i was like oh this is the most
amazing thing and she just wanna like
kind of sit in my lap and give me a hug
we're in the pool a hot tub
um and then she starts like she does
this thing every now and again where
she'll like scratch my beard
um
and she's scratching my beard i'm like
this is the most amazing thing of all
time like i'm here with my daughter it's
just she and me
um
and she goes daddy i was like yeah baby
girl and she goes daddy you have a black
beard but it's always white right here i
was like oh
[ __ ] kids will say the darndest things
they'll tell you the truth talk about
truth
that's what kids do man
zero building maya p what advice would
you give your younger self
my my ip
your younger self which advice what
advice would you give your younger self
um
ah that's a great question
uh
is this gonna sound a little
bizarre
because not everybody is is fortunate to
have this experience
but
live life
as if
life is long
and that sounds weird because a lot of
people say like life is short do it up
uh
but then you have kids and you have a
spouse and or not your jobs or your
bills
and you go like okay well maybe this is
this is life like let me let me
enjoy it if you i think sometimes you
know when i was when i was in my teens
and 20s
i kind of did the life is short like do
it up
um
and then
in hindsight now i'm realizing that my
favorite experiences
are when i lived life like life is long
like let every let relationships grow
let
uh yourself grow um and don't be so hard
on yourself is one thing don't be so
hard on yourself yeah please man i'm so
hard on myself that's the worst it's
like give yourself a working break
yeah you know
that's that's that's the way i'm wired i
don't want to let people down
yeah
you know and you've got a lot to like
you get you don't want your wife down
your kids down your crew down your
friend like you've got a lot going on so
it's it's easy to go there and you got
to try not to go there david h david h
says both of you guys keep talking about
how the book isn't closed on
supernatural how unclosed is it
uh david h uh
the book is not closed on supernatural i
mean obviously there's a prequel coming
out um
but beyond that as far as
jared playing sam and jensen playing
dean
uh
you know if if a new book is released
then i think i would be excited to try
and help tell that story
did you and uh jensen settle
did the dust settle with the whole thing
when he uh announced that the
supernatural prequel and then you
tweeted and all that stuff did you guys
have a talk and have a laugh about it we
had we had to laugh and cry man uh
really
yeah we i mean
you know we're we're two
grown ass men with with
spouses and kids and mortgages and
uh car payments and this and that um and
so
we
we did link up
uh
or sync up or whatever and talk on the
phone and i've seen him many times since
obviously he just directed we were just
in uh
some city together
denver
las vegas
las vegas denver
uh dallas
i've seen him many times uh we were
together uh
in austin um three or four days ago uh i
love the guy man like and he loves me
back i have no doubt
and
i think he and i would both rather
things had gone down a different way
they didn't but that it's not productive
to to say like who's to blame or what
happened
it's productive to go like
i mean i feel part of me feels like
you know if if you are in a relationship
with somebody
friend family whatever
and you haven't gone through hardship
and you don't really know
it's once you go through a hardship of
some sort
and then your instinct goes to like i
want to make this right where i want to
say goodbye to this
uh
and he and i both figured the former
like hey i want to make this right like
you know
this is going to sound like
hey everybody out there like go get in a
fight with people you love and that's
not what i'm saying but too strong of a
friendship to let something like this
kind of get get you
sure yeah yeah things i mean
goddamn like
can you name anybody you
you love and have spent this much time
with as an adult
uh as a sovereign adult human being
that you haven't
kind of been like dude like i wish this
was different yeah
i wish that was different so i've said
the wrong things i've acted dif
the wrong way this is this thing called
life
again it comes back to not being hard on
yourself you know what i mean or
the people you love
we're straight man i mean i i i want to
be really clear
because i know
you know you always see
like twitter trolls and stuff of course
man
all that so i want to be abundantly
clear man like nobody believes in jensen
more than i do
you said that baby you said that and i i
yeah it's touching it's touching i think
he'll you know him hearing that he knows
how you feel about him he knows
he knows yeah
uh so what's next besides
is next just tomorrow it's next just you
just take it day by day is it the kids
the it's the family it's the wife it's
the show it's the prequel you've got
enough on your plate is there anything
else that's going on that you're uh
you're uh thinking about
a badass nap like right now
oh yeah once we hang up i'm gonna
tell you i love you and
do you nap
do you nap naked or with boxers or with
a t-shirt and boxers do you keep your
socks on what is it you know what man
i'm mysterious so i nap however you
think i know
i'm gonna say you nap in your underwear
dude
here's okay i'm gonna answer honestly i
i
i nap
uh
in inapp and
like under armor
like sweats kind of not really sweats
but they're like the tom
brady says like hey this helps
circulation i don't think it does but
they're cozy uh
i always run hot and so i don't uh
i don't like sweats sweats but like i
sleep i don't sleep naked i don't
have naked like i like being i'm like a
like a
proverbial cancer like i want my shell
and so i want to like i'll nap in a
beanie and a long sleeve shirt and socks
and you like being toasty
but i well believe me the room is like
62 degrees or something
but i like uh jenna's always like why
are you wearing so many clowns
and uh
i'm like
you know and also part of me being a dad
and having three kids now
part of me is always like well what if i
have to like wake up and chase off an
intruder you don't want to be naked
yeah well i don't not want to be naked
but i'm just sort of maybe that would
really help chase him off if you were
naked
maybe well like what does ronnie karen
even say like if he's ever
uh if someone's ever gonna start with
him he just drops his drawers like no
one wants to fight the naked guy
it's very true
dude this is always a damn treat it's
always a damn tree talking to you i know
you're busy as [ __ ] i appreciate you
taking the time
i love you i can't wait to see you um i
wish you all the success in the world
let me know how the hyper chain
hyper
hyperbaric yeah hyperbaric chamber works
i will
yeah see they would they would i love
you buddy and i wish you all the best
i'll talk to you yeah talk to you soon
all right man homie ciao
yeah i always love talking to him i feel
he's one of those uh guests that i feel
like i could ask him anything and i
don't feel weird about asking him
because he'll either say he'll tell me
or he won't
but i don't feel awkward doing that
you know that's how i feel about him
that's good and a lot of people love
this guy i mean i i love this guy but
he's got such a huge following and uh
it's always nice to see the numbers
shoot up and then fall back down after
he
the next week's episode but uh you know
uh again thank you guys for listening
thank you guys for
um being so supportive and choosing the
podcast inside of you as your podcast
for the week along well i'm sure you
have others but uh
uh yeah it's it's nice um right now
a reminder may 28th two shows my band
sun spin 2 pm 6 pm
check it out a lot of cons if you want
to listen to the intro of this whole
thing you can hear
a bunch of other stuff how about that
you can just rewind and listen to the
beginning and you can hear about the
inside of you online store and a bunch
of other stuff but right now we're going
to go to our top tier patrons thank you
jared padalecki for joining us
um i appreciate you buddy and these are
the top tier patrons these are the folks
that give extra and uh i love you and
thank you for supporting the podcast
go to patreon.com
inside of you
to become a patron of mine a patron of
the uh yeah a patron of mine i'm going
to write a song called the patron of
mine
what do you think
it'll sound like angel of mine
angel of mine
what's happening oh god
i don't want to say brandy or monica but
i could be wrong
someone figure it out for me
[Music]
i don't know here are the top tier
patrons nancy d leah s sarah v
little lisa you kiko jill e brian h nico
p robert c i n b
yes b jason w kristen k raj c joshua d c
j p jennifer and stacy l jamal f janelle
b
kimberly e mike
e
l dan soup
remo
99
more ra mira santiago m
m and you see them i just thought yeah
that's what i said i think you said m
chad
w leanne p maya p maddie s belinda
and chris
h dave h
wow you're doing really well today
sheila
g brad d ray h to tabitha t
tom and liliana
a yes talyah
d mmm chad l
rochelle
marion marion
uh meg
k that's right trav l
dan n
big stevie w angel m rhiannon
c correct corey
r k super
sam dev nixon michelle k a a jeremy c
andy t cody r gav and nader david
um
boreanaz
c c david c john b brandy d uh
vore camellia camille and s yes the c
correct joey uh
fatone m willie f david h omar i design
otg eugene n mm-hmm
eugenie lit lil lee
leah
chris p nikki g cory nicole patricia
heather l jake b
uh james b
bobbitt
joshua b tony g megan t mel s orlando c
john b caroline r rob e paul c christine
s sarah s eric h spring jennifer r shane
r m r
mark m jeremy
jeremy v that is the those are the top
tier patrons those are the folks that
give extra they give the most those are
the the givers
and uh thank you for all the support and
the love on inside of you and uh thanks
for for being here again thank you for
uh choosing the podcast i really
appreciate it um many great episodes
coming up i hope you stick with it and
revisit us and if you like jared
padalecki the least you could do is
since you liked it at least stick around
for another episode that's all i ask i
mean is that asking too f and much is
that so effing much is it so f and much
god but from myself michael rosenbaum
and me
ryan tears here in the hollywood hills
of california i'll give a little wave to
the camera we thank you for listening we
love you be good to yourself that's the
most important thing be good to yourself
and uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
and uh a real joy i just went to a uh
comic con uh in st louis and it was
great and the people there were awesome
and so many people really loved the
podcast and it's nice to see people
coming up
talking about the podcast so thank you
we'll see you next week
um on inside of you with michael rose
tomorrow
[Music]